what what is the bigger picture here
because it's not just about vaccines
right it's they've lied to us about so
many things right they've lied to us
about elections they've lied to us about
who's racist and they've lied to us
about gender and all of the stuff then
this story came out yesterday this is
from The post-millennial Meta so this is
the parent company of Facebook now meta
promotes former CIA agent to head of
election policies after spearheading
2020 misinformation team
is there a better example that I could
possibly ever show you we could do the
show for the next 50 years I could
literally be 97 years old we will be
doing this show from from most likely a
mental institution actually and I will
be trying to tell you people that that
was the best example of democrat
privilege ever this guy who worked at
meta to deal with misinformation even
though they have been the spreaders and
the amplifiers the hyper amplifiers
through algorithms of misinformation
maybe more than anybody right maybe
Facebook just by the sheer numbers
there's more people on Facebook than
Twitter let's say they have spread more
misinformation than anybody they stop
people from questioning things about the
vaccine and covid and elections and
everything else and then what happens
this guy is going to now be in charge of
their election stuff for this upcoming
election
do you think something weird's going on
here uh let's flash back once again
today's a big flashback show let's flash
back to all the way back four years ago
uh this is a Mark Zuckerberg greatest
hit uh when he was on The Joe Rogan
program confirming uh that the FBI
actually did come to Facebook and they
pushed him to censor the hunter Biden
story
how do you guys handle things when
they're a big news item that's
controversial like there was a lot of
attention on Twitter during the election
because of the hunter Biden laptop story
yeah so you guys censored that as well
so we took a different path than Twitter
um I mean basically the background here
is the FBI I think basically came to us
some some folks on our team it was like
hey
um just so you know like you should be
on high alert there was we we thought
there was a lot of Russian propaganda in
the 2016 election we have it on notice
that basically there's about to be some
kind of dump of of um uh that's similar
to that so just be vigil guys guys FBI
is going to show up some stuff might
happen so be vigilant right and what you
have to understand is as I always tell
you guys this is a mafia move that the
FBI put out there they did not say
assuming that what Zuckerberg said there
is true they didn't come to Facebook
offices and say you can't put any of
this stuff up or ban all of these people
or anything else but they basically had
something's coming and you better watch
out right you better look out and that's
the ultimate Mafia move when the mafia
walks into a restaurant because they owe
him some money and they say well this is
an awfully nice Pizza Joint that you got
here it would be shame if something
happened to it and then three weeks
later it burns down so you you
understand the move that they are making
here now now Zuckerberg also that's not
to excuse Zuckerberg because now not
only do we know that the hunter Biden
laptop story was real and by the way
plenty of people did plenty of free
thinking people knew it why did I not
fall for it go back to all of our videos
when this thing was happening before the
the before the last election and I
always was saying I was saying I don't
know exactly exactly what's on it but
sounds like something's there and the
fact that they're going so far out of
the way to hide it the fact that Twitter
itself pre-elon Twitter uh was hiding it
not only the links they wouldn't let you
link to it they suspended the New York
posts account but then you couldn't
privately message direct message is what
there is what you privately message with
someone on Twitter privately nothing's
private they wouldn't even let you
privately send the link to people